صباح الخير طبعا قبل السبعين عام من الان
كان هذا المحل خاص بصناعه النحاس او ما
يسمى بالصفر في العراق بعدين تحول هذا
المحلي بيع السجاد لكن مو سجاد عادي ولا
بوسط اعتياديه هذه البسط مصنعه يدويا على
ايدي نساء عراقيات همم من طوائف مختلفه
ومن اديان مختلفه هذا يعني هؤلاء النساء
اليوم عم عدنان راح يتحدث لنا همم عن قصص
هذه القصص الاواني انه حاسيه وعن قصص
السجاد وايضا عن قصصه هو يعني همم هو همم
صاحب هذه البسط والاواني الى قصص مختلفه
همم صباح الخير عن عدنان
صناعه الاواني النحاسيه الى بيع السجاد
المرور الزمن قبلت 30 40 سنه
وبعض الي كان يسوي دقون
ماتوا وكبروا ولدهم موظفين
صار دكتور هو يتعبون الصفاري
من الصبح
طيب حدثنا عن هاي البسط هاي البسط شنو شنو
عمرها شو تميزها للبسط قلت منهم النساء
اللي كانوا يصنعون هاي البسط هذه الشغل
يعني جنوب العراق
[موسيقى]
طيب
عمرها 100 سنه
عابديه خاله الملك فيصل الثاني دخلت للمحل
هذا
حدثنا شلون شلون كانت دخولها لهذا المحل
وشرائها بعض التحفيات من عندك بابلي دخولك
انت في بيت الملك فيصل
الجو اثنين
لابسه عبايه
واحد رياضيه ثاني مرافق يعني
دزونا عليكم ابو عدنان عنده لمبات قديمه
وفرفوري
[موسيقى]
اشتروا مني بدا كويت 20 دينار بس شلون
كانت دائقه الملك بعد ان دخلت بيت الملك
يعني
في البيت هل كانت فخمه بسيطه
تنتظرهم وين المتحف العراقي
شلون كانت دائقه في البيت هناك البيت
[موسيقى]
العائله عائله الملك في ذلك الوقت همم
بسيطه عن عدنان
سؤال اخر ابرز الفنانين والمشاهيل
يا زينه
اوكي منهم كانوا ابرز الفنانين والمشاهير
اللي التقيتهم هنانا وخاصه سمعت انها
التقيت الفنانين عرب ايضا
فيلم خطايا وانا شو احب الاغاني احب احب
امن احب ما ادري يعني ياحبي
ب
كلمه بضعه ومن حضرتك بوسط او اواني نحاسيه